the Special Air Service or SAS is a
special forces unit of the British Army
founded in 1941 this unit performs a
number of roles including covert
reconnaissance counterterrorism direct
action and hostage rescue the SAS was
established to assist in highly
classified more unconventional
operations during World War two
in 1945 the war was over the British
government saw no further need for the
force and the unit was disbanded but
within a year it was decided there was a
need for a long-term commando unit and
the SAS regiment was reestablished in
1947 the majority of the information and
actions regarding the SAS is highly
classified and is not disclosed by the
British government or the Ministry of
Defence due to the sensitivity of the
operations in fact it wasn't until 1980
that the SAS gained notoriety worldwide
after the televised hostage rescue
during the Iranian embassy siege after
the reactivation of Team rainbow in 2015
for SAS commanders were recruited to
bring their skills and expertise to
assist in the fight against terrorism on
a global scale these commandos were
called sledge fetcher mute and smoke
[Music]
[Music]
you
sheamus Khaldun codename sledge is an
attacking operator in team rainbow born
and raised in the Scottish Highlands
sleech has a physical presence that
demands attention and respect in his
younger days he was the captain of the
1998 Scotland national under-20 rugby
team he has a strong desire for public
service and we're not to enlist in the
army at the age of 18 after five years
of duty he was recruited by the SAS to
the stage sledge still holds the
all-time speed and strength record for
the easiest qualifying physical exam his
professionalism and tactical abilities
are top tier and made him an a temporal
member of the SAS he was expected to
perform at the absolute highest level in
his new role as a rainbow operator over
time Sleeps developed operational
expertise and breaking down barriers
using a breaching hammer his specialised
tactical breaching hammer is known as
the caber and can breach through almost
all non reinforced surfaces of
barricades with a silent yet aggressive
pace breaching hammers are nothing new
to counterterrorism law enforcement but
what makes the caber so unique is its
exceptional size and weight for most
agents this will be cumbersome and
impractical but sledges exceptional
physical prowess makes them a formidable
presence on the battlefield allowing for
a quick and effective breaches
GPS satellites unmanned rooms for King
laser sights the more cruelty you have
the mauryas when they kicked out from on
the edge
if there's one thing I know for sure if
the de six-inch blade never loses
reception Mike Baker code-named betcha
as an attacking operator in team rainbow
from Biddeford England he comes from a
family of dock workers on his 18th
birthday he enlisted for active military
duty a veteran of three Wars Thatcher
was the oldest SAS operative on active
duty until he was recruited by rainbow
he saw action at the Battle of goose
green during the Falklands conflict he
was involved in the rescue operation of
the Iranian embassy siege in 1980 and he
was a veteran of the Gulf War Thatcher's
performance on and off the battlefield
and during two major political conflicts
made him a natural fit for VIP
protection duty he is highly proficient
in close quarters combat and as a world
caliber expert and anti electronics
operations Thatcher is highly observant
calculating and decisive while he may
come off as grumpy and impatient is a
profound sense of ethical responsibility
it is recommended to assign Thatcher
with junior operators of strong moral
conviction of whom he can mentor
Thatcher is equipped with eg MK o EMP
grenades when throwing they will let out
an electromagnetic pulse after a few
seconds either destroying or disabling
all electronics within a 5 meter radius
mark shandur codenamed mute is a
defending operator and team rainbow born
in York England mute graduated from
secondary school at the age of 12 a
child prodigy he went on to complete an
internship at a British tech company
where he worked on prototypes for a new
security system and then at the ripe old
age of 14 who is accepted into the
University of Cambridge mute is highly
intelligent in analytical he is used to
being the smartest person in the room a
man a few words who prefers to be short
and concise with passing information and
because of this is often misread as
being rude mute is equipped with GC 19
money signal disruptors witcha portable
devices that can be placed on the floor
to jam electronic devices developed by
britain's government communication
headquarters the money was originally
designed as a portable device that could
block out any radio transmissions for
covert or sensitive meetings between
British government officials and foreign
interests as one of the primary
engineers on this project you created a
variant of this device there has doubled
the effective range of the original GCHQ
signal disruptor
I know what you're wondering what's in
the canister I could tell you but then
I'd have to kill you
Amala machina burn relax as for what's
in the canister
diversity donor James Porter codenamed
smoke is the defending operator and team
rainbow smoke was not an academic
although in secondary school he excelled
in science
he took a particular interest in biology
especially the topic of dissection
during his gap year Smoak enlisted in
the British Army using a fake ID in
order to avoid getting parental consent
after basic training smoke was stationed
in Belfast but he found the posting a
bit dull in the wake of the March 2007
treaty he went on to join the army
boxing team as a middleweight smokers
are thrill seeker with very little
regard for his own personal safety he is
fearless in battle and it could be a
great asset for defensive maneuvers
however he seems to enjoy the havoc and
chaos of war just a little bit too much
and he has an odd sense of humor when
placed in stressful situations Smoak
requested a portable device system that
could deliver the most damage to
intruders in a targeted area who is
equipped with compound zip a promote gas
grenades using a remote detonator smoke
and view the results from the distance
the mines are filled with a collection
of biological substances that on their
owner inert but when combined ever more
volatile affect the resulting concoction
will damage or kill anyone exposed to it
even if enemies are not caught in the
gas it's thick enough to act like a
normal smoke grenade blocking vision in
the area I'll continue to cover the
operator teams with the FBI being the
next group I'll admit it's hard to find
much on these guys until you get some of
the new ones but I have my Tom Clancy
research team on this so anything that
comes up will be found and by Tom Clancy
research team I'm really just talking
about my go to Tom Clancy law phonetic
Brenes anything I'm unsure of and want
double-checked he's my man
though I think he just started
University so this channel market he'll
now
wish me luck you can find reneus on my
disability server anyway thank you very
much for watching and I'll catch you in
the next one
Cheers
[Music]